This boring ICT strategy made me over
$2.5 million in thirdparty verified
profits after years of failure, and I'm
about to show you exactly how. I've been
trading ICT for 8 years, and in that
time, I tried dozens of complicated
strategies, and this was the one that
finally made me profitable. Today, I'm
going to break down all three steps of
the strategy so you can use it to become
a profitable trader. The goal of this
strategy is to distill ICT concepts into
what actually matters because 95% of it
is just going to confuse you. Now, this
first part is stupid simple, but if you
mess this up, nothing else works. So,
let's first talk about choosing a
direction. Now, the importance of
choosing a direction and identifying
where the market's going to go because
if we get it right, we should be paid.
So, one of the first things that I look
at is market structure. So, is the
market creating higher lows and higher
highs or is it creating lower lows and
lower highs? If it's creating higher
lows and higher highs, we can just
assume that the market is in a bullish
market environment. And if it's creating
lower lows and lower highs, we can
assume that the market is in a bearish
market environment. So to simplify this
as much as possible, think about markets
just going in three main directions.
It's either going up, going down, or
it's going sideways. So when we try to
identify a bullish market structure,
this market can go up and down, but it's
usually not going in a straight line
like this. And what we're trying to pick
out are the areas where it pulls back.
This is really where we're trying to
position ourselves long for the market
to continuously drift higher and higher.
And vice versa, if we're predominantly
bearish on a market, we're expecting the
market to create lower lows and lower
highs and position ourselves on these
pullbacks as the market drifts lower.
So, when it comes to analyzing this
specific market in 2023, we can see that
it was in a major bullish trend. And
yes, there were pullbacks along the way.
But even with these deep pullbacks,
they're still not creating new lows in
the market. And it's our job to
understand and say, okay, this market is
moving lower over time. Let's just say
from midFebruary up until mid-March,
this market is in a short-term
downtrend, but eventually we get a
higher low printed here and it starts to
move higher again. And likewise here for
the bearish example. You can see here
that it's creating lower lows and lower
highs. And we recognize that this market
does have short-term rallies like this
one and here, but overall, it's still
creating a lower high compared to these
previous highs. So again, the first
thing that I try and determine is, is
this market creating higher highs and
higher lows or is it creating lower lows
and lower highs? And if the market is
unclear if it's making higher lows or
higher highs or lower lows and lower
highs and it's just kind of chopping
around sideways, then I don't even move
on to the second step of identifying the
direction. But let's say it's clearly
identifiable in one of these short-term
rallies. So here we have a low, a high,
a higher low, a higher high, a higher
low, and this market is continuously
trending higher and higher. and it's
easy to identify that we are in an
uptrend. Next part of identifying the
direction and I do that by looking at
fair value gaps. So if you guys don't
know what a fair value gap is, it's
basically a three candle pattern where
we have candle one, candle 2, and candle
3. You guys can see here that we have a
bit of a gap from this wick to this wick
here. And all this price action in here
now becomes our fair value gap. This
essentially just represents an imbalance
between buyers and sellers. So, if
bullish fair value gaps are being
respected and bearish fair value gaps
are being violated, we can determine
that order flow is currently bullish.
So, if we just zoom into this chart
right here, I've marked out a bunch of
different bearish fair value gaps and
bullish fair value gaps. You guys can
see that the bullish fair value gaps are
being respected. Meanwhile, the bearish
fair value gaps are being violated,
meaning we're trading and closing
through them. So, each time we get a
bearish fair value gap, it's violated on
a closure above that specific level.
Now, there are more fair value gaps in
this chart, but I've only plotted the
ones that really jump out to me. And
opposingly, if bearish fair value gaps
are being respected, but bullish fair
value gaps are being violated, then the
order flow is currently bearish. So,
here we can see a ton of bullish fair
value gaps. Once we get this bearish
fair value gap though, it starts
violating all of these levels in here.
And as you can see, each time we get a
closure through those levels, the market
continues lower and creates lower highs
and lower lows. Now again, if market
structure and order flow are unclear,
then we have no real direction and no
trades. All right, now we have the
market direction, which is great, but
pretty useless if we can't execute
trades consistently. Which brings us to
step two of the strategy. Now, if you've
ever been stopped out only to watch the
trade rush in your direction afterwards,
then this is for you. After you learn
this simple concept, you'll never be
faked out of a trade again. All right,
so let's talk about how each day is
actually formed. And I'm going to
simplify this as much as possible. So on
a bullish day, we have an open, a low, a
high, and a close. So the lower part of
the body of the candle is our opening
price. This wick down here represents
the lowest price that it traded on the
day. Wick up here represents the highest
price that it traded on the day. And
then the top of the body of the candle
represents where it closed on the day.
Now, let me try and break down how
you're trying to position yourself in
the market. And this is something that
really transformed my trading. So, on a
bullish day, my goal is to buy it as
close as possible or below the opening
price. Because if I'm anticipating the
market to close higher, who's going to
get the best price on the day? Is it the
person that's going long right at the
open or below the open? Or is it the
person that's going long after the
candle has already flipped bullish and
pushing towards the high of the day. So,
let's just assume, for example, that I'm
entering at the open and John is going
to enter after the market is already
trading in the direction that we're
expecting. All right. out of mine or
John's orders, who gets the better fill
price on the day and is able to extract
more profits from the markets with the
least amount of risk? Obviously, in this
example, I would benefit from entering
at the open compared to John waiting for
the candle to already turn bullish
because I'm buying it at a discount. So,
let's just assume that the opening price
is $5, right? And John is entering at at
say $750 and then this market actually
closes where? At $10. So, let's say it
opened at $5 and it closed at $10. Who
makes the most amount of money on this
specific day, Kyle or John? Clearly, I
have because I made $5 profit on the
day. Meanwhile, John has only made
$2.50. And let's just assume that our
stop loss is all the way down here and
the price of this stop loss is going to
be $3. So, I'm entering at $5 and my
stop loss is $2, right? So, if it goes
to $3, I get stopped out and lose $2.
Whereas, if John enters and he gets
stopped out, right? We're using the same
stop-loss. He's losing $4.50.
Okay? So, John is losing almost twice as
much as I am. So, from a risk-to-reward
perspective, you are trying to buy the
candle before it expands. And if I sit
down in front of the charts and the
candle has already expanded, I typically
will not take a trade. So, on a bullish
day, I'm trying to buy it at or as close
to the open as possible, ideally below
the open. And on a bearish day, I'm
trying to sell it at or as close to the
open or ideally above the open if I'm
anticipating a bearish candle. All
right, so now you know how to find out
which way the market's going and how to
avoid fake outs. But how do we actually
make money and find the best trades?
Now, this brings us to step three,
placing the trade. So, for the entry,
we're trying to keep things as simple as
possible. We're looking for a sweep of
liquidity. That might be an intraday
higher low, session higher low, or
previous day higher low. And then we're
just going to enter on a fair value gap
with the expectation that the daily
candle is going to close higher or
lower. So in this one example you guys
can see here our midnight open and
leading up into a news release which I
believe this was NFP. You guys can see
that we took out sellside liquidity into
this fair value gap. And also note that
this is our daily open. So this trade
meets all of our criteria. Maybe we had
our market structure and our order flow
already predetermined coming into the
day. What we're trying to do is buy it
at or below the opening price as closely
as possible. Now, if you sit down in
front of the charts and the market is
already trading all the way up here, I
am less likely to take on that risk
because look how far we are away from
the daily open. When you sit down and
back test all of your trading data, you
will realize that on the most bullish
days, often times the best buying
opportunities are going to occur at low
or very close to the opening price. And
if the daily candles already expanded,
you are assuming more risk. Now, here's
just one more example. So, let's assume
we have a bullish bias coming into this
day. Maybe the higher time frame market
structure is still trading higher. And
again, if we're anticipating this daily
candle to close bullish on the day,
trying to buy it at or below the opening
price and we're looking for a raid on
liquidity. So, we have our raid on our
London session lows here, trading down
into this fair value gap. We get a nice
rejection. So really anybody that's
going long after the sweep of this
doesn't really matter if you're entering
it here, here, here, here, here,
anywhere below or at the daily opening
price. At the close of the day,
everybody that entered around these
prices will close the day in profit. You
now have the same strategy that I used
to make millions of dollars and changed
my life forever. But chances are, you've
probably had profitable strategies
before, but still didn't become
profitable. And I get it because I
failed for 10 years before I was able to
make it work. But once I did, my life
changed forever. Please guys, whatever
you do, just stay consistent with this
because trading really can change your
life if you have the right system. I
recently opened up spots to my inner
circle where I trade with my students,
give them my full system and coach them
to become successful traders and
overcome the hurdles that are keeping
them stuck. Due to this being a direct
mentorship, I only work with a limited
number of traders. If the link in the
top of the description still works, then
slots are open. If not, then feel free
to apply for the next enrollment. Thank
you guys for watching.